hi I'm Jacqueline this is chigan people
have been waiting for this footage since
d23 and comic-con so we're here to break
it down the new trailer for infinity war
the next in the avenger saga there was
an idea see this is how it's the
trailers are supposed to be done to
bring together a group of remarkable
people to see if we could become
something maybe not I just like the Hulk
like showing us what things need us
characters have a backstory yeah so I
know who they are when they get on the
screen yeah I know who Black Widow is I
know who Hawkeye is I know the romance
between the Hulk and I mean I get it
Thor and the Hulk are buddies we saw
that in Ragnarok we know who black
panther is like Marvel is doing this
right pause right here so Marvel Studios
this week has basically culminated with
this trailer first thing they did is
they had the Vanity Fair covers with all
of their folks then they released the
poster which is very simplistic poster
but it's still got people really really
hyped for the film yesterday they
released this thing on Twitter where
they had fans kind of commenting on the
fact that we're about to finally see
this footage I hate to say it but they
totally just shaded any kind of buzz the
Justice League had with what they've
done this week like they gave Justice
League like a little bit of time like
ten days from their premiere and then
they just came back with like oh you got
your little team up let me show y'all
how it's done I mean I hate to say it
but I mean I don't hate to say they Big
Brother them they were like this okay
little brother you want to do a little
we've been doing a vendor's and a group
group movies for a while let me show you
how it's done
Marvel Studios is doing it well they're
doing it correctly and this trailer
speaks to that I totally agree
you will know what it's like to lose
right there posit spider-man with a
spider sense that is the first time
that's been really shown to any degree
in this new version of spider-man and
like when I first saw this because that
was in the d23 footage ah like people
jumped up and started screaming so Peter
Parker in New York riding the bus still
a high school student and he looks and
turns and sees Loki is supposed to be in
this one but we don't know which side
he's supposed to be on and he was right
there holding the tesseract which is one
of the gems that make the Infinity
Gauntlet so all through this point in
the trailer we've heard this voice and
if you don't know it's Thanos who's the
big bad big bad of this film is played
by Josh Brolin we saw him in guardians
we saw him as the first teaser in
Avengers like this shows how much Marvel
is this is chess not checkers and he's
also father to nebula and Gamora from
guardians of the galaxy so there's again
this is the tie-ins I'm begging for when
it's done correctly yeah everybody in
the book so so we're gonna get into what
fantasies after and what he's here but
it just goes to show you the difference
in this team-up is like when he shows up
because he's been woven into the other
stories we kind of already know that
this guy does not play around I think
you know there's a the the final shot
where you see him grab the Infinity
Gauntlet and he's like fine I'll do it
as one of the other like post-credit
scenes room previous films it just again
just goes to show you that they just
keep weaving these stories through -
we're now 17 movies later when we go to
the infinity war we get it we're all
dialed in and we care and this movie
which has gosh more stars than I can
count
we we care about each and every one of
them well and here's and here's a quick
thing before we get right back into it
sins of the CGI which you are always
talking about they show us the village
yeah okay DC this is what when you when
you do a villain right you can actually
show him
the trailer unlike Steppenwolf who we
were absolutely assaulted by in your
movie Justice League I hate to shave DC
so much of this trailer but let's go a
little bit like we're working with
reality
so this Meccano this is fan out this
looks to be his big entrance and I love
like if you read the books on Thanos
what what he looks like here is a
perfect melding of both Josh Brolin's
face because it is a CGI character on in
the comic and what's been drawing the
comic again it's just not checkers man
they're just doing this so well let's go
[Music]
Spider Man in a new suit and I have a
feeling that this is supposed to be the
spider-man suit that's available to be
used in outer space because there is a
storyline in the comics where spider-man
kind of goes to outer space and this
looks like that suit I think it's called
like the ultimate spider-man costume
don't don't get mad at me in that one of
the comments from wrong fit that's this
he's like he's like gather your dislike
like get everyone get it evacuate the
city
fortify your defenses and get this man a
shield like oh my god Chadwick and then
we see him come out of the darkness
right with the beer I'll be the first
ladies oh here we go oh it's gonna get
written 'cat oh girl
we didn't know he could look that he
look good before I don't mean to
objectify you but the timeline of my
Twitter feed is already awash with how
much women are like don't ever put that
that like unbe r did Captain America we
don't ever want to see him again Jews
had black panther
strong brother from the motherland
Captain America comes on with a beard
and all of a sudden you absolutely I
still love to Charlie
I still love Chadwick but this is new
this is new that's T'Challa bread like
I'm not buying all of that good all
right here we go
Scarlet Witch right here pauses so
pause it okay what we just saw was the
Hulk Buster costume and that's the
costume that Tony Stark used in civil
war to basically like capture Hulk like
and get him or was it some more
either one where Hulk went crazy yeah is
a jolt Ron sorry so many movies
age of Ultron he basically goes a little
crazy because Scarlet Witch like
mesmerizes him and he uses the whole
Buster to try and like fight him that
did not look like a toady stark old
buster
are you trying to say that there could
be someone in the halt buster costume
that's not Iron Man because that
speculation going around and office
perhaps it's the guy that has the
namesake like maybe they put the Hulk in
a hole Buster costume again
Wow speculation it's true but you know
here's the beauty of it we widely
speculating about Marvel you know what
we never speculated about DC we never
speculated about Justice League DC
anymore because honestly this trailer is
the highest form of shade really you
know what exactly
[Music]
all right Robert Downey jr. taking the
jewel off of them so the Infinity
Gauntlet has six stones and the stones
themselves are the time/space soul
reality power and mine gem now the one
that vision has is the mind gem and
that's the one that kind of sits here in
yellow on the top of his forehead and
you see the tesseract go to his forehead
like they're trying to claw it out of
his head and then you see they're not
putting the mind gem into this but this
is what we call the Infinity Gauntlet
which is this basic glove that Thanos
has because his whole goal and this is
what's so great about Marvel they've
already set this up is to get all of
those gems there was a scene in
guardians where Benicio Del Toro's
character talked about these magical
Incas Benicia they toured the collector
the collector and then you know in
guardians they were trying to prevent
that one getting to Ronan the destroyer
and that was the one that you know at
the end
spoiler alert of guardians they all held
it together and you know whatever that's
part of the plotline chess not checkers
so now when he puts this in the gauntlet
we know he's collecting all these stones
when he gets that Infinity Gauntlet it
basically makes him invincible he can
destroy worlds he can create worlds he's
he's godlike in every way so when they
say the end of the world in this it's
like the end of the galaxy he goes for
Michael Clayton's I am Shiva the
destroyer crazy okay so here we go and
by the way those two gems look like
honestly it's the one from guardians of
galaxy and it looks like the blue one
from the tesseract is what those look
like in my little Eagle Eye here we go
[Music]
right there in Wakanda baby love it love
it this is all this all looks like it's
right in Wakanda which I love posit
right look at all of them just so let's
just pick off who they are and so you've
got Bucky you've got cap yes you got
black Pandora malate that looks to be
denied we're right there with them that
was their first confirmation that she's
gonna be an infinity war which I love
and in the back we have war machine
looks like war machine is back Hulk is
back and they're all right in front of
all the work on and look who's flying
you got Falcon right there in the back
with his wings outspread Falcon on the
right side so I mean a lot of these
characters we didn't know where they
were gonna end up at the start of
infinity where we definitely don't know
where they're gonna be at the end of
infinity war because the the rumor if
you will is that you know contracts are
up we've raised the same people want to
do this some people want to say it might
be killing some of these people like
this may be the last team up that we get
to see and I honestly like that it's
because this this movie and the in this
and the second part of infinity war
which is yet to be names it could be
like Game of Thrones like they can just
start killing people and it'll be real
and and you don't and you expect it I
mean personally for me well one of the
things I would end with us who we think
might die cuz that's don't say we who
you think my dad yet I do but I will I
will say this the word liked it I think
person with the number one thing on his
back is the one they showed in the
trailer and that's vision because again
if you have one of the things that
Thanos wants in your forehead they might
bring it back I just love the fact that
we're in this freeze-frame
you're seeing people that have had
standalone movies that you have actually
felt some type of kinship with it you've
grown with them so we kind of we've
grown with black panther we've grown
with the Hulk we we know who Falcon is
as an ancillary character because he's
shown up in different movies we
definitely know Captain America Black
Widow Bucky
war machine we know who these characters
are alright let's roll
[Music]
this is the image that essentially
creates a poster this right here love
the score and then again
put this right here you guys posit Oh
guardians that right there no I'm so
glad I wore my shirt today because to me
this was literally marvel trolling it's
like we just gave you this trailer we're
showing you all this team ups and you
know how much we have characters you
know how many characters we have we're
just gonna toss the guardians of the
galaxy at you right toy with you play
around let's let's just show you how
good we are right how big the hammer is
that we swing okay because this is what
we do and again you the tieing if you
saw Thor Ragnarok yeah you saw him lose
his eye yeah all of a sudden infinity
war he they were cutting on a spaceship
sorry if that's spoiling Thor Ragnarok
where they get on the spaceship and Wow
oh my gosh they're in space and he meets
up with the guardians of the galaxy the
tie-ins are great it's so well done
everything is sifted and and comes out
bit of the cake baked so perfectly you
can enjoy it's not just jointed yeah I
again I go back to my sentence when you
talk about Marvel it's chess it's about
the long game it's about putting all the
pieces on the board and stacking them up
to where when they come for this which
in a lot of ways this is like you know
the culmination of all the work that
they put together this far they they
they they have checked me like this is
this movie take my money it's a good
probably one of the biggest movies ever
made it's already got one of the biggest
production budgets and you know you
don't hear about this movie problems
right about changing of directors it's
going to come also on the heels of black
panther which I know you are
anticipating I'm anticipating they're
gonna hit you with like a like like
almost like a one-two knockout funniest
thing I will say about this when we talk
about the social media interaction so
the trailer drops this morning everyone
goes crazy you know infinity war is
trending on Twitter you want to know
this the one character who is trending
the most from and this had so many
characters like 25 you know characters
from 19 so just lay it on me black
panther that was the only character name
that was trending on top of the movie
name which I think just goes to show you
that they featured him so much in this
is this almost like a teaser to Black
Panther as well it's
again I love caramel this is what I
would say is probably the most
anticipated movie for me at this moment
for 2018 this is more anticipated no not
one of the most anticipated Black
Panthers number one and this would be
the second who's gonna die that's the
voice of our producer who has his own
wild theories we call him sleeping
vision and also who was absent in this
trailer
Hawkeye Hawkeye was not in this trailer
at all now I know he's supposed to quit
the Avengers but come on Thanos is
coming you don't think he's gonna like
team-up all of them will be back I'm not
gonna wanna speculate that somebody's
gonna die what I will tell you is there
are people that I know I would like to
see I think everyone should take out
life insurance on Captain America and
vision that's my personal over not
killing Captain America they're not
killing me they're not gonna kill
Captain America not after they just gave
him your sexy beer do you love his beard
someone said I don't kill him tell us
what you guys think about who may or may
not be making it out of infinity war
alive as again that is speculation but
we love to speculate and that's it for
us today thanks for joining us that's
all I have to do all I have to do is
give you the hammer and you know what
I'm talking about
boom we're out of here bye guys
[Music]